hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el castor cibernético
de radio canadá internacional radio
nacional el servicio internacional de
radio canadá internacional que el
servicio en español
la emisión que le ofrecemos cada siete
días cada semana que sería de la del fin
de semana si no son esta emisión y yo
vivía la cosa al contrario que sería de
nosotros sin de fin de semana este finde
sin nuestra misión es del fin de semana
porque la compañía acá de los que nos
están viendo teniendo para nosotros es
el motorcito que nos impulsa a estar de
voz
[Música]
y exactamente le damos la bienvenida a
todo lo que nos sigue a través de
nuestros diversos canales de
comunicación que son facebook live
youtube
rc y net punto sea barra oblicua y s o
español como ustedes quieran poner o
español también que esas son las vías
por las que nos pueden seguir y nuestra
aplicación de aplicación
que nos está mostrando ahí y leonardo
primero así es la aplicación
únicamente en francés está bien no se
escucha pero a ti nada musiquita de un
hombre en realidad y estamos viendo cómo
es de fácil navegar nuestra aplicación
se puede ver la emisión en vivo en
realidad es la versión inglesa pero ahí
pasamos al español y usted puede elegir
la lengua que queda en este caso estamos
viendo como la nave y en chino que
sonaría nuestras cinco ofertas no es
cierto francés e inglés lenguas
oficiales de canadá español y árabe y
chino
efectivamente así que ustedes pueden ir
a estos lugares
crédito de promoción de nuestra
de nuestra creación aplicación se
encuentra en todas las tiendas para
teléfonos inteligentes android está ahí
ustedes pueden ir desde nuestro sitio de
internet y hacer clic en la imagen de la
publicidad y directamente puede ir a
escucharnos cuando le dé la gana
bueno como sabemos son los equipos
móviles los que son utilizados cada vez
más para acceder a programas de radio
como este para vídeos a programas de
televisión para que llegue el 5
5 de mayo informado que estaba cómo
evoluciona la cosa verdad al principio
se hablaba del punto g y ahora ya vamos
en el 5 g
la tecnología cómo cambia la tecnología
es una locura además de saludados lo
vamos a poner un poco de orden esta
emisión y vamos a presentarlo porque no
dijimos hasta ahora quienes estamos aquí
en el estudio
y estamos hoy presentes paloma martínez
que está saludando ahí pablo gómez
[Risas]
y leonardo gimeno novio insultante
exultante
pero que no sean insultantes lo que
exuda sexualmente
tú mismo tu persona aquí al mando de
este barco no termino una presentación
como verán estamos aquí nuevamente en
nuestro estudio habitual esperamos que
llega ya que nos hayan acompañado
primero y que hayan disfrutado la
emisión del viernes pasado que dedicamos
a la al mes de la historia de la
negritud en ese centro
donde nos recibieron con los brazos
abiertos y un espacio de difusión de la
cultura africana y negra en general
bastante interesante en pleno centro de
montería no muy lejos de acá a pocas
cuadras aunque para irlas caminando con
el mundo por todos lados es más
complicado sí pero esperamos poder
repetirla
experiencia con otro tipo de ámbitos
también de hecho estoy esperando que
llegue realmente el buen tiempo el
calorcito etcétera tenemos que hacer un
día una transmisión desde la terraza de
estudio final
me parecería maravillas mañana en la
noche
es la noche en vela en vela
aquí en montreal a noche blanca la noche
blanca ya nadie duerme en esta ciudad la
ciudad no duerme durante 24 horas y hay
todo tipo de actividades
tendríamos que arreglarnos para hacer un
programa durante una noche en vela
hablando de haber ido hace ya varios
años a una de las marchas de zombis que
se acercan no sé si es para el mismo
evento de la noche blanca o acerca de la
noche blanca y yo me acuerdo que hacía
un frío un frío así aquí yo no sé la
gente que estaba disfrazada con
maquillada con sus actos
y alegóricos a la marcha de los zombis o
de los muertos vivientes' o como quieran
llamarlos
no sé cómo hacía para soportar ese frío
porque era mucho menos bueno lo que es
cierto es que en la noche en vela la
noche blanca es parte del festival moje
a la línea en montreal iluminado
y las luces las luces de montreal
entonces es un festival que incluye
muchas cosas no solamente esta noche en
vela sino muchos otros eventos muchos
gastronómicos por cierto había un avión
festín gran concurso de sopas supe
porque había gente concursando uno de
los restaurantes mexicanos más conocidos
de acá estaban concursando para hablar
sobre las tortillas y no sé si ganaron
pero parece que compitieron bien en todo
caso está bien una competencia de sopas
y había también bueno hay una gran
rueda de la fortuna en la calle hay
muchas cosas en muchos eventos
relacionados se puede decir que es uno
de los y no el primero el primer gran
festival el festival que abre el
festival después sabemos que sigue una
cadena determinada de la gran terminal
efectivamente sí a lo largo de todo el
verano podemos hasta fines de agosto
creo terminan los grandes festivales
porque hay otros seis otras pequeñas
ciudades también pero estamos hablando
de pero ya hagan esa época del año
empieza a ponerse fresco como para
seguir disfrutando de los espacios al
aire libre y los y los festivales son
más reducidos y en espacios cerrados
aquí en esta parte de canadá porque eso
quiere decir que también está el
festival iglú fest que es otro de los
festivales fritos digamos frescos como
para no sólo musical digo creo que es
para niños también el inglés indica
actividades para niños ese es el otro el
festival de la nieve
el festival de la nieve
como tres semanas y fue suspendido
porque fui a uno de esos iglú fest una
vez que nos macro si no se hacía en el
puerto y efectivamente
dos años se vio que la gente se dice ah
me voy a ir a cine más con mi chamarrita
a mí
no hay que vestirse bien doble capa
triple capa
algún trago que pueda ayudar
y música electrónica y música
electrónica por una al por mayor
billonario quería decir así aquí tengo
dos saludos gente que se comunica con
nosotros por nuestra plataforma facebook
que yo ni willy navarro y saludos desde
la ciudad de lima donde se está
disfrutando hermoso verano
asimismo informarle que un fuerte sismo
de magnitud 7 se registró la madrugada a
8 kilómetros al noreste del distrito d
sang haro provincia de sangre o región
puno en el perú sigue un abrazo grande a
johnny willy navarro y después el luis
balderas y muy feliz oyendo vuestro
programa desde el puerto de san antonio
en chile el pasado 25 de febrero
estuvieron de aniversario y no lo
elegimos todavía más nada en el año 1945
comenzó a transmitir radio canadá
internacional por onda corta hoy los
seguimos a través de las plataformas
digitales pero la tradición e historia
en la radiodifusión internacional se
mantiene muchas felicidades y para que
los que tengan ganas de ir a recorrer un
poco la historia de radio canal
internacional puntualmente de la sección
española y de radio grand internacional
en general hay un sitio especial que se
hizo para el aniversario número 70 donde
estás que está yo es lo que buscar y voy
a poner el link para que puedas verlo en
el magnesio y a pesar de tantos años a
pesar de tantos años a pesar de que hoy
transmitimos a través de la web y por
ende a todo el planeta que tengo ven
tiene universo hay mucha gente que
todavía no nos conoce
y sobre todo aquí en canadá cuando
estamos buscando gente para hacer
entrevistas en español sobre todo si se
trata de canadienses que hablan español
hay muchísimos canadienses que no saben
que existimos y que se sorprenden porque
nos dirigíamos más hacia un público
internacional
hace ya varios años que estamos
transmitiendo a través de web y a mí me
gustaría que nos conocieran más tenemos
que hacer una campaña de difusión a
nivel nacional y me parece que nuestro
redactor en jefe nos decía en algunas de
las reuniones que tenemos por ahí
esporádicamente que casi más del 50% de
nuestros auditores son canadienses en
este momento lo que nos siguen ahora son
canadiense y igual renta nacional en
español es el que más gente tiene que
nos ve desde afuera debería hacerlos
chino no deberían ser la entrada está
prohibido todo todo y bueno para
aquellos que quieran ver el nuestro
70 está ahí 70 años si somos cuando hace
74 años así que hace 4 cumplimos 70
contar muy bien si antes de esto estudió
matemáticas
si tenemos bueno un montón de historias
y reportadas de entrevistas y tal que
tienen que ver con la creación y lo que
fue radio canadá internacional lo que es
en este momento y bueno aquí una pequeña
línea de tiempo como fue progresando y
progresando y cómo se se conformó lo que
hoy se conoce como radio cada
internacional y por supuesto hace un par
de años atrás cuando cerró la banda
corta también hay elementos que muestran
esa parte un poco triste también de
nuestra historia y recuerda que la
semana pasada les envié no estaba yo
aquí pero les envié también una página
en la que encontré la última transmisión
que hicimos por
pero me contestó el mensaje si es que
encontré por ahí un blog de uno de
nuestros oyentes que había retomado la
transmisión del castor mensajero pero
también la de canadá en las américas de
la época antes de que cortar la moda
transmisiones por onda corta si no me
equivoco en nuestro amigo horacio negro
de oro de la galena del sur que es su
revista de
de auditor de onda corta y guarda en sus
archivos esta transmisión llevada a cabo
en el año 2012
2012 fuera fue en junio del 2012 egipto
para mejor
bueno para que nos siguen a través de la
web vamos a tener como siempre un poco
de música en este caso se trata de una
artista canadiense de origen sudafricano
porque sus padres son sudafricanos y se
llama jeryll cohen que vivió de hecho en
sudáfrica la llevaron muy pequeña sus
padres allí luego paso por berlín un
tiempo hasta que decidió retornar a
canadá y se radicó en la costa oeste del
país en la provincia de columbia
británica ella tiene una larga historia
como reportera y editora independiente
pero en el año 2015 se decidió mejor
dicho a darle rienda suelta a su otra
vocación que es la de música la de esta
música ya que cohen y lanzó en el 2015
su primer álbum que se llama exa el
exilio
vamos a escuchar dos temas musicales uno
precisamente es ese exilio y otro walk
away que podemos traducir según el
contexto de la letra cómo te vas te va
más que vete qué fue lo que yo pensé en
un primero entonces como objetivas como
que abandonas como que ante la situación
en lugar de hacer frente a estas webs y
sabiendo que estás construyendo
efectivamente así que van a tener
quienes nos siguen a través o que nos
escuchan a través del sitio internet
triple w
r sí y el punto sea
necesitamos revoltosos con problemas que
no conocen el retruécano retruécano a
esa forma de pronunciar la erre que nos
solían enseñar en la escuela el
retruécano que el más común es recoger
reciba roer
el barril rápido ruedan los carros sobre
los rieles del ferrocarril de cero
dile a un canadiense que lo repita agro
colombiano son que son intentado
el ferrocarril decía el rápido ruedas
las ruedas sobre los rieles del
ferrocarril
más rápido
[Risas]
trogloditas
efectivamente porque esto se está
desmadrando haciéndose fuera del lugar
bueno pues son los temas fuera de lo
habitual que les han sorprendido esta
semana que es lo que hacemos la atención
que es lo poco convencional que les
disparó la curiosidad tengo uno que me
pareció muy curioso de un muchacho
esteban un muchacho
señor si steve chen se llama 39 años no
es tan viejo así que hablamos con
nuestras edades venerables es muy es muy
joven
entonces este este este señor que es de
la ciudad de québec estuvo tuvo que ir
al palacio de justicia de trova rivière
porque él la policía lo encontró lo
detuvo manejando con las facultades
debilitadas por droga sí y aparte de eso
por haber causado daños se robó un
vehículo entonces estaba estaba drogado
y aparte de eso causó daños por cinco
mil dólares
se puso a pelear con el policía que lo
detuvo y intentó huir pero lo curioso de
esto es que el vehículo en cuestión era
que este señor se robó un bus estos
autobuses estos autocar de una compañía
que se llama new orleans
un autobús enorme que iba en contravía
es sorprendente que lo hubieran detenido
imagínate entonces me pareció me pareció
un poco loco e insólito poco
que te vaya a robar un bus y sobre todo
ponerte a manejar en contravía con tu si
no era necesariamente para escaparse
alta velocidad no no no no no él iba muy
campante ahí en su bus iba solo
a buscar los clientes
en alguna otra noticia que esa se
llamaba la atención forma pues yo para
para variar no perder la costumbre
hablar del invierno ha habido varios
fenómenos particulares en relacionados
con este invierno que ha sido muy
especial porque hemos tenido de todo
hasta tsunamis de hielo se acuerdan y lo
vieron la imagen no tenemos una imagen
para que la gente que no la porque no la
puedo ver mira que son bloques de hielo
gigantescos que no llovió un vídeo no sé
si ustedes lo vieron pero el vídeo es
que el agua empuja en el en el lago
ontario a un lado de toronto de la gran
ciudad de toronto el agua con con el
viento hoy que fue tan fuerte al
principio de la semana el agua está
congelada entonces con el viento y la
corriente interna del lago empujaba los
bloques de hielo como si fueran bolas de
hielo sigan aspirando y haciendo una
montaña cada vez más al vídeo
y otro fenómeno que me pareció
particular
el de un círculo perfecto de hielo
también lo vieron sobre un lago un
remolino un remolino de hielo que crea
con la corriente interna un disco
perfecto que se giró exactamente giraba
por sí mismo sólido y se crean así
naturalmente creo que es la primera vez
que se ve uno a quien que ve que en los
últimos años pues que lo hayamos filmado
estela está la imagen no sé si hay uno
bueno pero es perfecto y es hermoso
también pero bueno son las cosas lindas
del invierno duro nosotros adoramos a
este el vídeo de las dos bloques de
hielo a un lado del lago ontario mira
los arbolitos de ushuaia ya y si de
suerte que estaban ahí fueron ellos los
que llegaron en este caso pero hay un
vídeo que muestra cómo van acumulando
pequeños tsunamis porque generalmente
los regalos one am los tsunamis real en
zona mito son olas gigantes estas serán
como quiera olas bastante grandes citas
min a mí es una muestra más de lo que ha
sido este invierno en particular como si
fuera a llamar la atención habitual
entonces yo los voy a combinar con una
noticia que sí es interesante y en todo
más interesante
nuestro como no termina mi frase que si
es interesante sobre todo para los niños
sobre todo para los niños que suelen ser
amantes de los animales en el zoológico
de toronto ha nacido un bebé cebra
se trata de un pequeño macho de cebra
que es el tercero en nacer en el
zoológico de toronto y es de una
variante de especie de cebra que se
llama cebra real o cebra grave
que se encuentra en peligro de extinción
figura en la lista de en la lista roja
de especies amenazadas según la unión
internacional para la conservación de la
naturaleza que hermoso
es negro con blanco y la cebra es blanca
con expresa
[Música]
además de lo maravilloso de esos que
están buscándole
un hombre jefe es una práctica que se va
a hacer que es utilizar el zoológico de
toronto otros zoológicos del país
también pero toronto en particular que
es el de invitar al público a sugerir el
nombre de los animales que nacen allí en
este caso hay una especie de opción
cerrada porque hay una lista de nombres
o cuando leáis la información por
primera vez dije bueno esto da rienda
suelta a la creatividad de los chicos
para que se les ocurra en nombre de la
cosa que les evoquen no sea algo
importante en sus vidas etcétera y si es
más o menos así pero hay una lista de
nombres que sugieren el zoológico que
tienen que ver con combinaciones de los
nombres del padre y la madre de este
cerebro este pequeño secreto
el padre se llama jake llamado jj y jake
juniors
[Música]
proponen llamándote j dj
[Risas]
porque la madre se llama tory entonces
es una unión de los dos nombres story y
6 que la madre y otra cuarta opciones
gobierno
exacto que son los nombres que se llaman
de la guerra de la guerra y que porque
dos cebras que nacieron anteriormente
llevaron nombres de personajes la guerra
de las galias sigamos con la tradición
la invitación está hecha pero también
hay gente cierto que puede si prefiere
otro nombre si se les ocurre otro nombre
que sea más creativo más interesante
para ponerle este pequeño se brito como
dice pablo se puede escribir al
zoológico y decir mi nombre es a mí no
me gusta ni yo surgir o tal
porque saben hay otra cosa que soy
nombrada por los niños y que yo me
enteré casualmente hace dos días son los
viajes espaciales nombrada por niños y
señor
perdón las naves espaciales el audi y el
infiniti y todas estas naves que
salieron de cabo cañaveral fueron
nombradas por vuelas si señor hacen un
proponen nombres hacen una especie de
selección de los 45 me les gusten
después los someten a votación en las
escuelas alrededor de cabo cañaveral
sabía y por eso se ponen esos nombres
entonces hagamos un concurso porque
ahora con la nueva carrera hacia la luna
de la que va a participar tramada con la
con la nasa está acá nada va a construir
este nuevo brazo como le llaman el
canadarm 3 brazo robótico entonces en
lugar de llamarlo canal arma 3 que suena
muy raro podríamos encontrarle un hombre
también por poner los chicos que con el
nombre
una sugerencia para lula porque papel es
la paloma
[Aplausos]
para los papás de todas las opciones que
integrada a achantar y bueno
sap sap y papeles de creatividad y mucho
más en el brazo robótico y bueno en
realidad
saludos johnny willem navarro que nos
dice en realidad cuenten conmigo para
poder irradiar su programa en canadá
donde hay muchos peruanos que hacen
historia dicen nos dice son johnny y
gustavo luca y se van a estar de saludos
desde melo departamento del cerro largo
en uruguay gracias ya volvemos
o
[Música]
ah
hola
[Música]
ah
bueno y vamos a darle lectura a algunos
de los mensajes que nos hacen llegar por
distintas vías también nuestros oyentes
porque en el caso de los mensajes que
son impresos se nos están acumulando
tenemos cada vez más para comenzar con
los mensajes yo tengo aquí un mensaje un
comentario para el reportaje
conservación o pérdida de la residencia
permanente y ciudadanía en canadá es
guillermo que pregunta que dice hola
vivía en canadá cuando era niño mis
padres tenían residencia pero después de
unos años decidieron dejar el país
hoy soy adulto y quisiera recuperar mi
residencia canadiense es posible aún
tengo mi pasaporte de niño con la
residencia gracias
habrá que informarse yo creo que sí ya
tenía la residencia la embajada en la
embajada de su país no sabemos de dónde
espero que vaya directamente a la
embajada canadiense en su país y ver si
hay que reactivar el archivo y
suficiente yo creo que no es tan
complicado
otro mensaje si yo aquí tengo un mensaje
sobre la embajadora de cuba en canadá
realizó una visita oficial a la
provincia de québec y andré
nos dice buenos días muy buen informe en
las páginas en español de su sitio web
de la visita de quebec a quebec del
embajador cubano en canadá sin embargo
actora sin embargo dice nos gustaría que
este informe se traduzca el francés y se
coloque en las páginas francesas de
saint et y si podemos imaginarnos por un
momento que el embajador o embajadora él
escribe embajador de cuba está visitando
la provincia de ontario sin que se haga
una traducción al inglés en las páginas
de inglés de radio klara internacional
piénselo dice me gustaría repartir entre
mis muchos amigos europeos el trabajo
que está haciendo en el sainete gracias
por la atención que prestará mi
solicitud no firma entonces andrés clic
bueno tendremos en cuenta la sugerencia
pablo hay un mensaje si acá está nuestro
buen amigo y fiel oyente es javier
gonzález nunca hará y que dice me
reporto presente en canadá en las
américas café y les envío los cordiales
73 desde guadalajara méjico y también
está gustavo lucas que dice bueno
saludos desde melo departamento de cerro
largo en uruguay bueno yo quiero dar
cuenta de las cartas que se nos han ido
apilando a lo largo del tiempo y digo
bien cartas porque son cartas
efectivamente que vienen seguramente sí
señor como divino son cartas que nos han
quedado archivadas o que nos han quedado
hay una carpeta de hace ya largo tiempo
de todas maneras no queremos olvidarnos
de la molestia que se han tomado
nuestros oyentes y agradecerles ese
gesto a joel gonzález que es de la
habana en cuba a rafael reyes plaza que
es de santiago de cuba- otra carta de
rafael también aquí va a basilio mendoza
santos que es de ciego de ávila a la
carta que nos hizo llegar también bueno
estas horas de rafael tengo aquí una de
l hernandez hernandez de guantánamo que
se tomó el trabajo de escribir varias
cartas que nos envió lo que nos hizo
llegar en el mismo envío etiquetas como
a la manera de informes de re merecido
11 se ha tomado realmente un un largo
rato para hacernos llegar todas estas
líneas por eso no queríamos dejar pasar
la ocasión de agradecerle el tiempo y
esfuerzo tomados y saber que aunque a
veces demoremos porque tenemos tantas
cosas que hacer que el tiempo no nos
alcanza no nos olvidamos de nuestros
oyentes vivan donde vivan y sobre todo
de nuestros oyentes cubanos que siguen
fieles al correo postal tardamos pero no
olvida pero no olvidamos otro mensajito
sí aquí tengo otro dice por su intención
de eliminar 18 mil expedientes de
inmigración que ve que es llevado ante
los tribunales y mailén nos dice buenos
días soy una persona que se incluye en
estos 18 mil mi esposo y yo llevamos más
de 5 años preparándonos en idiomas
después logramos en 2016 un cupo en
oye nuestra vida y ha girado en torno a
ese sueño hemos demorado decisiones como
de tener hijos para tenerlos allá ahora
vienen y nos quieren borrar en un minuto
todos los planes eso es inhumano e
injustísima dice ojalá la demanda del
lugar y nos siguen tratando el
expediente y podamos realizar nuestro
sueño muy buen artículo saludos desde
cuba pues nada más decirle que ya el
gobierno de quebec tendrá que tratar
esos 18 mil expedientes que había dejado
atrás y que había puesto de lado
entonces que no se preocupe nuestra
nuestra amiga que no está escuchando uno
otro mensajito
un comentario al reportaje recuperando
sonrisas un programa de dentistas
canadienses para mujeres marginales ya
que el índice 30 o 35 años y no tengo la
posibilidad económica para curarme los
dientes soy madre soltera y tengo una
autoestima baja entonces le recordamos a
jacqueline care la información
relacionada con este con este de con
estos dentistas canadienses está en el
reportaje
entonces para más información si pueden
si quiere ir a informarse tengo una duda
leímos el mensaje de luis balderas de
chile que decía éste que nos felicita
por el programa listo entonces
ya entre otros temas acá yo tengo acá
nada necesita inmigrantes muchos
inmigrantes en todos los sectores de la
economía gerardo y tal
gildardo andrade dice soy mexicano pero
fui deportado de eeuu por trabajar sin
documentos y me gustaría trabajar en
canadá con mi esposa y mi hija tengo 46
años y experiencia en restaurantes y
construcción principalmente la piedra la
violencia en mi país está muy mal
vivimos atemorizados todo el tiempo por
favor de llamar para más información
bueno
le aconsejamos más bien a nuestro amigo
que él se informe por su lado y que
trate de obtener más información por
intermedio de la embajada consular del
consulado
no sé en qué lugar se encuentra pero en
mexico en méxico puede ser un mensaje
que nos hizo llegar ricardo daniel
figari que dice hola soy de uruguay
ricardo fígar y soy enfermero vacunador
experto en sexo ortopédico
me gustaría ingresar al ejército
canadiense tengo 35 años y nos da su
celular su número de documento de
identidad todo esto a raíz del tema
el ejército de canadá levantaría
requisitos de ciudadanía para aumentar
sus efectivos así que bueno que en el
mismo en el mismo reportaje en la misma
información tiene todos los datos
necesarios sobre esta posibilidad de
sumarse
al ejército canadiense y si no en la
misma página del ejército ahí tiene
todas las posibilidades que la
institución brinda así que ricardo si tú
quieres si aún permanece con la idea de
integrar el ejército canadiense lo mejor
que puedes hacer es consultar la página
internet del ejército de canadá algún
otro mensaje para brincar en cada ven
encadenar con lo que está diciendo ese
sería el mismo mensaje louis se hará en
jorge rodríguez que dice soy colombiano
tengo 33 años y soy reservista de mi
país y quiero hacer parte del ejército
canadiense
espero poder saber que puedo hacer para
poder ser reclutado entonces pues le
aconsejamos a jorge rodríguez el mismo
hombro seguimiento que lewis acaba
denunciar con amor y otro comentario
para el reportaje indígenas presentarán
evidencia oral sobre efectos negativos
de expansión petrolera en columbia
británica y hernán comenta difícil
ganarle a la avaricia de las empresas
que son apoyadas por el gobierno triste
en este caso tengo un comentario sobre
la noticia neurólogo experto en
epilepsia ofrece consulta gratis en
español desde saskatchewan y catalina
nos dice hola doctor téllez tengo una
hija de 16 años de edad actualmente pero
cuando tenía 15 fue cuando le detectaron
y le hicieron un tag y me dieron y le
dijeron que salió bien pero su
encefalograma su electro programa salió
muy mal muy alterado y le hace consultas
médicas sobre esta información pero en
realidad tendría que ir a buscar el
contacto de este neurólogo el doctor ted
es para hacerle las consultas a él esta
consulta fue en realidad hecha sobre el
formulario de comentario de nuestra
noticia en radio calenda más
efectivamente ya continuamos
[Música]
bueno vamos a ir a los temas que
estuvimos trabajando en la sección a lo
largo de la semana tenemos 10 minutos
así que nos podemos explicar un poquito
más que de costumbre porque por lo
general siempre nos hablará en los
últimos cinco minutos apurados pero en
este caso le podemos dar un poco más de
espacio a cada uno de los temas que
ustedes han estado trabajando porque
hemos estado trabajando aquí en la
sección en español quién quiere comenzar
pablo gómez bauer si siempre yo no me
voy a explayar demasiado porque ya hemos
hablado mucho sobre el tema y
es un cariz especial de la cuestión
exacto así porque es esta semana la
ciudad de montreal en gran pompa ofreció
limpiar la limpieza de la nieve en las
entradas de las casas de las personas
con movilidad reducida algo que no sea
que se hace en algunos algunas
circunscripciones de aquí de en algunos
distritos debería decir de montreal pero
no todos son son macro que son 19
si no me equivoco aquí en montreal y se
hace en tres distritos de limpiar la
entrada de las casas de las personas que
tienen movilidad reducida y las personas
de edad también pero en el resto de la
ciudad no entonces esta semana se
ofreció ese programa para no para este
año porque ya es demasiado tarde pero
para el invierno próximo entonces la
gente que tienen problemas durante el
invierno para poder salir de sus casas
imagínense alguien que esté en una silla
de ruedas este invierno
como promo y yo sea la mayor parte de
las personas y hay una señora justamente
que forma parte linda gautier que forma
parte del reagrupamiento de activistas
para la inclusión de quebec que ella
misma está en silla de ruedas que decía
que es prácticamente imposible transitar
en las calles de montreal en los andenes
de montreal porque este año ha sido
particularmente
complicado se mucho hielo por todos
lados no se podía transitar ni siquiera
prácticamente para las personas que no
tienen la movilidad reducida entonces
para nosotros mismos entonces este
programa es interesante salvo que esta
señora linda gutiérrez de este rap lic
de este reagrupamiento de activistas
para la inclusión en quebec dice que se
necesita más que simplemente limpiar las
entradas de sus casas porque si no se
hace ella lo que pide finalmente es que
se haga una limpieza de la nieve
correctamente en toda la ciudad sabe en
vez de prometer que se le va a limpiar
la entrada de las casas si las personas
como hay una tendencia aquí que es a no
llevársela a nivel densidad desplazarlo
solamente de las calles y veredas y
dejarlas apiladas en distintos lugares
la ciudad pero no a llevársela como se
hace en otros lados y eso hace que en
invierno están problemáticos como éste
la nieve se vaya acumulando o se vaya
acumulando llega un momento en que no
hay más espacio para meterla
un lado entonces eso hace que se vio en
situaciones complicadas como las que se
han vivido solamente no solamente en
montreal sino en todos los alrededores y
en buena parte de canadá buena parte de
canales arriba comentario porque hasta
aquí escuchen mismos comentarios se nota
agua en toronto y vancouver no porque
hay menos nieve deportivo entonces allá
para terminar simplemente que ella lo
que pide es que se haga el trabajo
correctamente y que de todas formas en
vez de invertir ese dinero en programas
para las personas con movilidad reducida
que beneficie a todas las personas en
montreal no se explayó pablo proceso
cinco minutos así que pagamos partidos
yo les hablo de un estudio de la agencia
de estadísticas de kanamma de canal
que concluyó entre otras cosas que los
hijos de inmigrantes latinoamericanos en
este país tienen ingresos más bajos que
los hijos de 'ot' de otros inmigrantes
de otros grupos minoritarios y eso a
pesar de terminar con éxito sus estudios
universitarios
parece que los
los latinos canadienses de segunda
generación que son los hijos de
inmigrantes digamos de primera
eso que siempre dice que van a estar
mejor que los padres exactamente los que
tienen por lo menos un padre inmigrante
de origen latinoamericano tienen menos
probabilidades de tener empleos
altamente calificados y sus ingresos
medios se encuentran entre los más bajos
de todos los grupos de segunda
generación eso es lo que lo que concluye
lo que es cierto es que también hay una
buena noticia en esta noticia que parece
mala es que en general los hijos de
inmigrantes latinoamericanos como el
resto de la población inmigrante de
segunda generación tiene tasas más altas
de finalización de estudios
universitarios que sus padres entonces
terminan la universidad más que otros
si en el caso lo que quería mostrar yo
va a ser bastante cortito y tiene que
ver con la presentación como no lo
publicó esta mañana nos puede mostrar
pero les voy a mostrar en realidad ya
puse el álbum de fotos y las fotos de
esto que es la gran feria de los
teléfonos celulares que se realizó en
barcelon se realiza todos los años en
barcelona y es una gran confluencia de
todas las grandes fábricas más de 250
fabricantes y gente que trabaja en
cuestiones que tienen que ver con la
comunicación en telefónica en este caso
con la tecnología y la telefonía
convergen en él a finales del mes de
febrero en barcelona y hacen una muestra
de lo que están produciendo el año
pasado la muestra en realidad fue
bastante chiquitanos no hubieron grandes
grandes aparatos nuevos ni cosas que
llamaron la atención porque se habló
mucho de inteligencia artificial en este
caso sí estuvo muy nivelado y se habló
de la agencia de inteligencia artificial
de la conectividad de la cuestión de la
salud pero sobre todo se hicieron
presentaciones de cosas muy muy
interesantes como por ejemplo el bueno
lo que estamos viendo estas personas
durmiendo porque van de que son los
teléfonos que te aparecieron tres o
cuatro marcas que están preparadas
preparando sus teléfonos plegables
entonces igual todo es en este caso es
un prototipo los que están más avanzados
son dos o tres de las empresas chinas
también el samsung que es coreana están
avanzados en estos prototipos y bueno
para ver un poquito de que se presentó
en cada una de estas en que presentó
cada una de estas empresas mañana en tu
material es que no se presenta no no
sobre todo el desplegable porque hace un
gran evento
solo igual por ejemplo lo hizo lo hizo
samsung hace dos o tres días fue que de
belo este esta pantalla plegable y
estuvo presente en barcelona el único
que no se presenta que no colabora con
esto es donna karan bueno y por último
se les ofrezco les sugiero en todo caso
una entrevista que dice haber importado
que es un integrante de él mejor dicho
el director de comercio internacional
que una empresa privada aquí en canadá
él nos habla de una iniciativa de la
orden administradores certificados de
quebec para facilitar la integración de
inmigrantes pero en los puestos
directivos empresariales ese es un
segmento del que no se suele hablar
hablar perdón hay muchos inmigrantes que
llegan con altísimas calificaciones al
país que han desempeñado cargos
gerenciales cargos de decisión cargos
ejecutivos en sus países de origen y que
cuando llegan aquí no se ven en la
posibilidad de integrarse en ese mismo
nivel entonces la orden de
administradores certificados de quebec a
lanza
una especie de caja de herramientas para
la integración de esos inmigrantes
calificados en las que se pueden
encontrar cápsulas de vídeos artículos
temáticos testimonios de gente que ha
pasado ya por esas experiencias para
favorecer para facilitar de alguna
manera para orientar los inmigrantes que
quieran lo que quieran apostar a la
dirección de alta gama en la acera y
bueno como es habitual no nos queda más
tiempo ya está acabando nos están
sacando eliminatoria no pero ya dentro
de poco les agradecemos una vez más a
todos ustedes su presencia y estar
compartir el tiempo con nosotros a
partir del facebook lite de youtube de
nuestro sitio en internet esta red
nacional y de la aplicación móvil de la
que hablamos hoy no nos queda más tiempo
nos despedimos chao
[Música]
pues ala
cielos
[Música]
efe